well Donald Trump actually held a rally
in Georgia on Saturday we did a live
stream on YouTube twitch and Facebook
and he actually sort of had some new
material for once you know these these
Trump rallies have been the exact same
material for a very long time Communists
and marxists are taking over the country
is ruined unless you elect me unless you
re-elect me unless you put me back in
office as the sort of Shifting narrative
has been
um no one's making money anymore you
know under Biden you'll have to flush
toilets 10 to 15 times Hillary did bad
stuff the crowd chanting lock her up
like a time machine back to the year
2015. so it was a lot of repetition but
he decidedly and notably added
um that we need to take our country back
by winning in 2022. we predicted this
you predicted this we we all predicted
this when we wondered how long is this
going to go on right in December the
Supreme Court will say it was actually
Trump who won it'll be overturned in
January and then January became March
which became April or August or you know
whatever we knew that eventually it
would be well the midterms are coming up
and the way to take it back is just to
win in 2022. that shift seems to have
started and we saw Donald Trump on
Saturday start to focus on the midterms
in addition to calling Joe Biden a son
of a [ __ ] okay we're gonna get to that
that yes a former president calling a
current president a son of a [ __ ] it
was deranged it was Looney it was
humiliating it was pathetic
but this is a political movement with
power at least for right now and they
are shifting to 2022 and they could win
in 2022. Trump praised the border patrol
agents seen whipping Haitian migrants
with horse reins remember they said they
weren't whips so they weren't being
whipped well you could whip someone with
a horse Reign and that's what they did
this is the exact type of rhetoric that
fueled the El Paso shooter during
Trump's presidency take a look tens of
thousands of illegal immigrants have
overrun our borders in recent days while
laughing in the faces of our border
patrol agents
and they're going after the writers of
the horses not the people that came in
illegally isn't that incredible and
they've just put them under watch
they're in big trouble the writers of
those horses
most people would say they were doing
one hell of a job right don't you think
they're in trouble can you believe it so
ramping up the red meat the crowd tuning
in and out as they often do during these
rallies but really loving that type of
stuff and then Trump going very quickly
into 2022. this is the new thing
starting to talk about 2022 and Pelosi
and more this is the shift we predicted
this is the shift we've been waiting for
it's happening now
usual Battleground in our fight to
rescue our beloved Nation
we have great great people running many
of them are right here hello Marjorie
with your help we're going to take back
the house and send Nancy Pelosi back to
San Francisco
where she can work very hard to bring
back a city which he has helped to very
much destroy just like they're
destroying our nation they're destroying
our nation we're going to fire your
Ultra left-wing Senator Ralph Warnick
and elect the great Herschel Walker to
the United States Senate
and we're going to take back our country
from these lunatics
now of course the question really should
be what happened to getting back in
right the lawsuits the fundraising it
was going to be December January March
April that's just gone I guess it is
predictably so but no questions being
asked about what happened to all of that
taking it back now stuff now you might
have thought
now that the Arizona audit showed that
Joe Biden actually won Arizona by even
more than originally reported
that Donald Trump would ease up on the
voter fraud stuff but no Trump never
does that Trump never says I joked with
the live audience guys do you think
Trump is going to say hey we got the
real Arizona audit results and it turns
out Biden did win I was wrong sorry
about that I was wrong Biden did win of
course not of course not and Trump
doubled down and he actually floated the
idea without any evidence whatsoever
that maybe Barack Obama didn't really
win in 2012. and most presidents go down
in the second term even if they win they
go down Obama went down way down
but he won or I don't know maybe he won
who the hell knows everyone
nowadays with these elections who knows
everyone but he went down a lot
and he won so of course there's no
evidence of that but this is the game if
you're not sure who won 2012 as a
Republican
then maybe Donald Trump really did win
in 2020. that's kind of like the base
level game that's being played here and
sadly it has worked to capture the minds
of tens of millions of these trumpists
and unfortunately you know uh Sam Harris
actually had a very good piece he got a
um a question from a viewer about hey
why don't you have on like Brett
Weinstein and some of these people
talking about Ivermectin and all this
stuff and and debate them and Sam made a
really interesting point whatever you
think about Sam Harris's politics he
said the problem with these debates
where you have like a contrarian is that
at any time
they can say but what about x x could be
anything and if you don't know about X
to a lot of these folks that have fallen
for the big lie it comes off as whoa
you're not ready to rebut X then the
conspiracy theorist must be right and
this is why As Trump went further and
further into stuff and said hey you know
there were 5 000 people
uh about whom there was no record for
example which is like really vague
language if you're not immediately ready
with an answer the types of folks that
go to these rallies go wow 5 000 people
with no record that they were supposed
to be voting in that county I don't even
know what that means but nobody is
rebutting it so it furthers these
conspiratorial beliefs so it's very hard
to kind of like put them back uh in and
put put them back in the bottle for lack
of a better term Trump even then
mentioned
and this is just red meat right that
he's never actually conceded 2020. and
now remember concession is a mere
formality but it's another reminder to
fire up the big lie people and the
people who think maybe Trump will come
back take a look sir a great poster so
we got 63 million he said sir if you go
up one million votes you can't lose well
we went up 12 million votes and they say
we lost
but there never has been
you know there never has been a
concession you do know that right
the crowd including the strategically
placed blacks for Trump who were on
stage right behind Trump really reacting
to that one as you could tell the crowd
tuning out for large portions of this
but getting pulled back in by xenophobia
getting pulled back in by the stuff
about voter fraud As Trump calls it now
in this next clip Donald Trump actually
admits that he called Brian Kemp in
Georgia after the election and asked him
to do a new election a so-called special
election just because why not right
maybe Trump would have won that one
instead of Joe Biden news
but I said to these young people let me
handle it I was going to show them how
good I am
I'll call him up I said Brian listen you
know you have a big election Integrity
problem in Georgia
I hope you can help us out and call a
special election and let's get to the
bottom of it for the good of the country
let's get to the bottom of it for the
good of your state let's go election
Integrity what could be better than that
sir I'm sorry I I cannot do that
now Kemp was right you can't just say
I don't know let's do another election
because you don't like the results sir
you you can't do that Kemp was right
Trump mentions Mark Zuckerberg from
Facebook the crowd starts chanting lock
him up and Trump says yeah we we should
look at that officials also took 45
million dollars from Facebook's Mark
Zuckerberg to fund election related
activities
[Applause]
well they should be looking at that and
what what is that all about so
completely dystopian completely
authoritarian I am increasingly
convinced that Facebook is a net
negative for society but lock up Mark
Zuckerberg it's the same type of
authoritarian stuff that they claim to
be for Law and Order and due process
except when it's the Trump rioters
subjected to that process they say oh no
no just let them out and you know
whatever uh and then when it's someone
they don't like like Mark Zuckerberg
just lock them up lock them up what what
crime or is even suspected of guys Trump
also tried claiming that the Arizona
so-called audit which remember it
confirmed that Joe Biden won actually
says Trump won it's all lies take a look
yesterday we also got the results of the
Arizona audit which
which were so disgracefully reported by
those people right back there and the
headlines claiming that Biden won
[Applause]
that Biden won our fake news and a very
big lie you know they like to you ever
notice when they write about that they
would say while the election results are
a big lie even the biased audit
confirmed that Joe Biden won and we're
gonna we're gonna talk about that Trump
then called for Arizona's 2020 results
to be quote decertified sir they just
confirmed you lost what are you talking
about decertification the total
decertification it is clear
in Arizona that they must decertify the
election you heard the numbers and those
responsible for wrongdoing must be held
accountable it was a corrupt election
Trump is the one responsible for the
wrongdoing and he should be held
accountable without a doubt uh no Trump
rally is really complete without some
glitches and uh short-circuiting Trump
short-circuited on the word obliterating
uh came up with obliterizing just a
little bit of the flavor and color but
Joe Biden is obliterized he's just
obliterating yeah and then he also had a
doozy of a time with military
installations which I I guess
instantations is the way he sees them
military institutions and their
installations and they have a lot of
things surrounding maybe he meant
instantiation somehow I don't I don't
really think so uh and then the former
president also claiming that people are
finally starting to say Merry Christmas
so the truth is no one really stopped
this is just that culture War stuff but
he did pull that out as well that's too
much and you know they are starting to
say very strongly Merry Christmas
remember when I first ran I said you're
going to say Merry Christmas they're all
saying Merry Christmas again we better
move fast because that'll end also like
everything else yeah so again the the
very interesting trend is we've talked
about how the Republican party has been
totally devoid of policy for at least as
long as Donald Trump has been at the
Forefront
um you can tell in the reactions of the
crowd they get bored when Trump reads
numbers or when he goes any into
anything that could be considered
remotely policy oriented of which
there's very little it's not even really
policy it's just like lies about the
policies you're ascribing to others the
crowd Tunes out they're interested in
xenophobic stuff about it was great that
the migrants were being whipped they
tune into a voter fraud stuff and they
tune into the culture War stuff we will
say Merry Christmas or we've been saying
it thanks to me or whatever
um and then like I said at the top yeah
Donald Trump referred to Joe Biden as a
stupid son of a [ __ ] take a look very
hard and then
[Music]
they had said well I will say that no
soldiers have been killed in 18 months
and there's people screaming at him
don't say that you stupid son of a [ __ ]
so again the crowd really loving it just
absolutely loving that so a wild rally
and listen for now it's clear Trump's
going to be involved in 2022. depending
on who wins and loses depending on
whether Republicans are
seen as being strengthened by the
midterms or further weakened he will
stay involved before that we don't know
yet it remains to be seen but there's
lots and lots of work to do uh and I do
to some degree
um uh coincide with the Brian stelter
article we looked at earlier I think all
of this together the Resurgence of the
rally the Trump interviews the escalated
conspiracy theories being spread related
to the election now that we're closer I
mean listen we're almost a year out guys
I do think there's something Brewing
here
it may just be some really uh low
information way to try to win the
midterms I don't know yet but we're
going to keep following it and we'll
have more on this on our Instagram which
you can find at davidpackman show one of
our sponsors is Shaker and Spoon the
monthly cocktail subscription box
delivering ingredients and recipes for
artisanal cocktails I've been using
Shaker at spoon to make cocktails at
home the last two drinks I made were
Citrus paradisi because I'm a big vodka
fan and sea fog with rum the whole
experience begins when you open the box
everything looks really nice they
include all the ingredients you need
except the alcohol with Easy
instructions I've been really impressed
with the results even if you know
nothing about mixing drinks like me you
will have a ton of success creating the
cocktails that Shaker and Spoon sends
you and you learn about Mixology in the
process success and widen your horizons
it's the perfect thing to do for a date
night I've had a ton of fun with it I
think you will too and you'll get twenty
dollars off when you use promo code
Pacman at checkout go to
shakerandspoon.com Pacman the link is
down below